Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number that
you can call any time of day. That number
is two one nine two David P.. Here's a caller
wondering about whether I'll be dipping my toes
further into financial YouTube. Take a listen
to this. I noticed. Hold on a second. Let's
play it from the beginning, please.
Speaker 8: Having the Kevin on your.
Hey, David. Huge fan of the show. I noticed
that you've been having the Kevin on your show a
couple of times recently, and I've actually gotten
some of my financial friends to get into your show
because of me, Kevin, being on your show. So I
was wondering if you were going to possibly have,
like Graham SAPIEN or anyone else in the quote
unquote, financial YouTube community. Thank you.
Speaker 1: I would be glad to interview Graham. I
think he's doing interesting stuff on on YouTube.
As many of you know, my formal training is really
in finance. And, you know, my my master's degree,
my MBA, my concentration was financial planning.
It's an area of personal interest. I always
hesitate to give advice and I try to make
clear whenever we talk about personal finance,
I'm not giving advice on the show. But if there
were to be like imagine that there was no more
political David Pakman show or
that I started a second project,
it would almost certainly be in the finance space.
So, yeah, I would be very interested in speaking
with Graham Steffen or being on with him and
talking about the sort of overlap between personal
finance and politics. And there really is a lot
there. I'm not sure if people in my audience would
be interested, but maybe there's a new audience to
be found there. All right. On today's bonus show,
Mitch McConnell and the Republican Party are
saying we can't play games, we can't play games
with the country's economic situation or finances
or the debt ceiling or whatever. Meanwhile, they
are playing games with the debt ceiling. So we're
going to talk about that incredible hypocrisy,
even though we're talking mostly about Beto
O'Rourke running against Greg Abbott in Texas.
Matthew McConaughey, according to polling,
might be a viable candidate. The actor Matthew
McConaughey wrote, We will talk about is Betto
the right choice? And then we will also talk about
McDonald's phasing out those plastic toys from
Happy Meals because they want to be more green.
When was the last time I was at McDonald's?
I will reveal it on today's bonus show.
Sign up at Join Pakman Dotcom and get instant
access to the members only bonus show.
Unidentified: We will see you then.